hey guys and welcome to episode 102 of
the last play and today hopefully my
voice should be a tiny bit better at
least hopefully I can get through this
recording without coughing or having to
slowly kill myself so that should be
absolutely amazing in any case the most
important thing that is going to be done
in this episode is making this windmill
and had this is this is going to be the
biggest stage of who ever since I built
that bridge but the biggest credits go
out two pieces of prestige who just so
happened to actually make this windmill
which was actually the funniest thing
since I was planning to have that Dutch
bridge and had no set to do it with and
I was just kind of thinking about that
kind of just crying about that and stuff
and piece of pastiche was like yo I'll
make a Dutch bridge no problem and then
that happened and then just very shortly
after that I needed a Dutch windmill and
what do you know piece of prestige made
a Dutch windmill so I don't know if it's
up for download yet I don't think so it
just kind of gave it to me there are
still some issues with the sets but if
it does get released I'll put it in the
description it's a really good windmill
set at least for the Dutch windmill
because that's the biggest problem that
I faced with this entire windmill there
is already station Jim's windmill set
which is also a really good set I've
just always had really big problems with
that set trying to get a sort of Dutch
look to the windmills and it's really
hard to get mat with it it's a very much
more international sort of windmill set
it is very versatile but doesn't get the
exact look that the Dutch windmills have
and I normally would have probably been
okay with any sort of thing but as I
mentioned in the last episode this
windmill is the weenie of the Dutch area
so it has to be really really well
pretty much one hundred percent like the
Dutch windmills that you see over here
in Holland and another very important
thing is the fact that you know the
windmills are very much one of the well
pretty much the only thing that people
really know when it comes to
architecture in Holland other than of
course amsterdam in general but the
windmills are really the most unique
sort of architecture thing that people
come to the Netherlands for so I really
wanted to get that in a certain way
that you only kind of have them in the
Netherlands and mm-hmm and basically
that's kind of where piece of the stitch
that came to be and why it was such an
enormous help to kind of have that and
the rest of this is just kind of going
to be spent trying to add some stuff
around the windmill and actually make
that look good I actually faced a couple
of problems with the waterfront area
over there as you can see there are
currently some flowers but one of the
biggest problems over there was that you
know obviously the in-game terraforming
doesn't allow any curves which is
already quite a bummer it's really hard
to even make any sort of curved
terraforming place that also has
vertical sides and I had to get some
custom scenery info dance but trying to
get that transition between the real
terraforming in game and the fake custom
scenery sort of cheated gross that you
can see the flowers being placed on was
actually really hard and actually faced
many problems with trying to get that
transition right and that's how I
actually came to kind of just randomly
have this idea that I would actually add
the little part that would go into the
windmill which is very confusing by the
way and basically windmills I'm not
gonna give a big history lesson right
history lesson with silver at the inning
I should have a jingle for that this is
not the first time this has happened
basically what the [ __ ] tone of
windmills in the Netherlands are
supposed to do is they pump the water
out because Netherlands is well at least
most parts of Holland are located below
sea level and if you don't pump out the
water is gonna turn into a sea anyway
regardless of how could you defend it
because rain and stuff and it just likes
to collect at the lowest place so you
need to pump out all that water and
that's what the windmills used to be
used for many of them still are but
they're like now there are motorized
things that do it way better but yeah
you need something in the windmills that
can suck up the water from whatever
canal it's next to and I just actually
accidentally just had that idea because
I had that really big problem with the
transition going from the in-game
terraforming to the fake terraforming of
like the water side over there and
wanted to cover that up with something
the initial idea was the house of rock
work
also looking at some pictures of real
life wit Mills I did realize oh I forgot
something these things pump water and
you have some sort of connection to the
body of water that they're next to and
if that connection is right over here
and in the end it doesn't just look very
and doesn't just look really good I kind
of like the way that this is starting to
shape up over here but it also really
helps to get rid of that annoying
transition and just got a nice little
waterfront area there without having to
worry about any terraforming glitches so
that that's why that was really awesome
and almost just a perfect thing right
there for me to have and the other thing
that I wanted to get in this meal and
this was a tiny bit of I suppose
artistic freedom that I decided to just
take there since most windmills are just
built and their own they really only
have the stack of the building itself
they don't really come out of any sort
of other facade or building but I wanted
to get something over here just a very
simple thing I wasn't really completely
content with not just the the shape but
especially also the size of the door
that came with it was exceptionally
small since you have to realize this
with this windmill is quite down skilled
in real life the mills are much larger
but if I wanted to make it like it is in
real life the mill would just completely
dwarfed the rest of the area but because
of that reason the door was also really
small and I did want to kind of make up
for that so the solution over here is
two and a tiny bit of a small building
next to it which would mean that there
would be no door that would not be
unrealistic where you compare it's in
proportion to the size of the windmill
itself but I get like an actual door
that's actually large enough for peeps
to possibly enter if you could do like
some stuff inside the windmill and
getting us little building next to the
windmill that also sort of covers a bit
of what was very empty over there there
was a lot of paths work going on and
this also kind of bridges the gap from
the windmill to the playground area so
that's why that kind of happen though
they're the only reason why i am using
wooden walls over there the wooden boats
that I've used before is because I
couldn't really find anything else but
surprisingly
greenwood actually went exactly like
really well with the greenwood that
piece of the stage had on his windmill
so in the end I think everything just
worked and at those points actually got
told to add some Swans in the water and
I couldn't find this one's like blackout
said that they were possibly in LG's
harbour sets which I can find them in
but LG's harbors that did have some
pretty cool boats so the scavenging for
boats had continued at that point are
still looking for some really good boats
I don't think there are any really Dutch
looking boats out there but just to kind
of get that feeling of the canal going
especially Amsterdam which is absolutely
riddled with boats in the canals along
with bicycles most of most of the things
in the canals of bicycles but there's
also many boats and wanted to get quite
some boats in there as well and since
office I obviously can't get the really
Dutch boats any sort of boats that I
find I figure is going to do that's how
that kind of happened now to talk about
this area which I currently just started
on in the Spanish area the way that this
is gonna be finished most likely at this
point is I'm gonna have some foliage
over here it's not going to entirely be
an atrium or anything like that but it
is going to be a tiny bit where the
building just kind of dip in to allow
some breathing room for the foliage as
well which for me all mostly just has a
couple of reasons I don't want to turn
this park into into like a too expensive
thing you can't have buildings
everywhere it's still a theme park and
not like a museum or anything and
foliage just in general is a lot easier
and quicker to place for me so that also
makes my job a lot easier and foliage
just looks really good like just having
foliage I'm not a really big fan of just
having foliage around areas but just
having buildings around areas is also
not a thing that I'm really a big fan of
it I like to actually kind of keep it
5050 though probably more foliage down
buildings probably 60 foliage 40
buildings Counting stations and things
like that is how I would kind of like it
to be that sort of ratio and this area
over here just had so many buildings
everywhere and if I didn't add some sort
of
gap in between the facades over here I
would just have one really really big
chain of buildings going from the start
of the park like the entrance all the
way through the main streets to the end
of the main streets to that main square
and then running back towards the start
of the park again at the end all the way
at the back of the Spanish area and that
will be the longest string of Hassan's
ever and I kind of wanted to break that
up a tiny bit the only problem that I
feel like I might be running into over
here is the fact that it's going to be
really hard to cover up all that foliage
I mean it's gonna be really hard to
cover up all the backstage area with
that foliage but that'll be a problem
for a different time I'll just kind of
procrastinates done and see what I'm
gonna do with that and that's probably
going to be next time and speaking of
next time oh man that's really bad
timing I see that I'm all out of time so
I'll see you guys next time thanks for
watching and I'll be the sayin